et je suis très heureux de nous voir
pour une journée de déconfinement non
mais c'est vrai voilà alors vous je vous
demander votre avis oui mais je ne vous
cache pas que je ne suis pas sûr que les
gens vous prennent au sérieux mais non
mais en fait je vois quinze mecs ils
disent oui mais en fait on est devenu
complètement fou ça fait un an qu'on a
plus de vie qu'on peut plus sortir on
veut plus aller au restaurant
là on commence à rouvrir partiellement
parce que tout n'est pas rose on a
encore un couvre feu jusqu'à 21h et vous
pensez que c'est précipité vous voulez
quoi rester confiné toute votre vie et
faire des zooms et faire des accusés
hydroalcoolique qu'elle va vous parler
en étendant du helmand non mais
franchement vous rendez compte
souple et non franchement de l'agitation
on est déçu on fait des chroniques comme
les soins survient bien sûr que c'est
trop précipitée ses rives oui c'est
contradictoire totalement le sanitaire
est oubliée c'est le politique et prend
le pas on fait n'importe quoi
- vous signale que par exemple la classe
de ma fille là elle est fermée 2,4
cowitz et fermez donc l'épidémie est là
la pandémie est là
et puis alors on va faire la fête
partout on n'y comprend plus rien la 4e
vainqueur
elle arrive maintenant ça fait sept mois
qu'on a envie celle bah oui bah oui mais
la précieuse machine le souhaitent ou le
vélo
non annonce à l'arraché quand il ya un
petit blanc on essaye de savoir si votre
gueule que je mets mon style non mais
voit franchement je trouve que ça fait 7
morts n'a fait quand même beaucoup
d'efforts oui bon ce qui va la situation
s'améliore il ya de moins en moins de
faim je peins sous l'autorité de mme eu
raison dans les zones à l'hôpital ça se
passe nuit me semble les chiffres sont
en baisse jusqu'à sotchi
donc il est l'heure de profiter vraiment
des l'hôpital la question un hôpital par
tailler jamais fait pas il demandé mais
attendez personne ne demande à partir de
lâcher ce qui se passe à l'hôpital chifa
sens et c'est l'hôpital qui était
chiffré mais ça marrant il ya un médecin
et un médecin et ammar table à chier
balauréa mais c'est vrai il est médecin
de santé publique il est parfois arrêtés
pour hâter de prendre pour quelqu'un qui
sait tout cette émission fait du bien
cette émission a mais alors il tombe dit
que c'est parce que j'ai trop d'énergie
bien oui il ya même le look est médecin
[Rires]
non le grenadien c'est important pour
moi ça me turlupine
non mais t'as fait d'accord il ya même
le modélisateur de plaster qu'elle dit
ce matin que si des chiffres étaient
meilleurs que ce qu'il imaginait il ne
croyait plus dans la quatrième vague
qu'il a annoncé acteurs et non ça c'est
vrai tout le monde est là brivistes
j'avais dit qu'il ya 100 % des gens
aujourd'hui élu safa pense que ça va
bien se passer et que non que personne
encore qui continuent d'être alarmiste
mais dans une posture idéologique
la décroissance elle est au delà de tout
ce qu'on avait imaginé donc de dire que
c'est trop tôt c'est totalement ses
passes cabine de belle maman hier soir à
la loire je suis je trouve que c'est
bien mais le dr amant il ya soit vous
êtes quand même des choses assez
raisonnable jamais bon dr amont à vous
aimer une personne a un portable à force
nous a mis la limite où les j'appelle
mon père oui oui oui oui
par contre on parle pas de mes couilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les murs mais je vous dis ça me jette à
easy alors malaisie par saddam et bah
oui à froid mais quand même on a
l'impression que gilles et monsieur
division vous avez envie que ça plante
mais non mais non c'est pas ça
globalement on a l'impression que vous
avez pas envie que ça fonctionne on n'en
peut plus comme l'a dit très justement
guillaume genton on a envie d'y à
l'autre à ado ça va pas bien
dis moi je suis à l'antenne l'apa
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dis moi pas tu trouves s'est précipité
pour à l'ouverture des terrasses ou pas
tout cela ait choqué je dis je dis pas
que c'est précipité c'est les gens qui
se sont précipités à bien les gens se
précipiter son côté des hôtes ils sont à
quelques mètres et ça ça te fait je
trouve je sois du mans parce que l'on
sent qu'il ya des jeunes c'est de
combien de temps je suis co vide le set
du gicl éventuellement il faut agiter
des rapprochements et là ils sont tous à
ses côtés mentalement chez les reds je
trouve ça complètement non l arabe
risque étudié à mon père d'assas votre
père louis-marie c'est pour dire qu'il
faut il faut comme ça il faut quand même
tempérer les choses
en fait dans cette maladie on sait rien
et en fait tout le monde c'est comme
s'ils avaient quelque chose à une foire
était un peu
[Applaudissements]
hélas ce maudit comme c'est donc des
gens intelligents peuvent faire des
abruzzes c'est toi et ta chance et un
truc de fou où il fabrique surtout des
camemberts tension c'est mon père qui
descendent d'ailleurs accroché là martin
auquel on répond dans docteur à nous
narrer du coup les contaminations
extérieures
même l'alliance américaine dit que ça
n'existe quasiment pas et se sont même
excusé d'avoir surestimé le risque de
contamination externe
je pense que les français peuvent
profiter en terrasse en revanche à
l'intérieur qu'ils fassent attention
donc pas d'après soirée d'after en
intérieur après ça s'appelle mention
spéciale gilles verdez à propos du
masque à l'extérieur c'est-à-dire vous
souvenez quand effectivement gilbert gaz
ici sorte un rapport de l'académie de
médecine de 2020 ces derniers qui les
lui et où le seul où effectivement vous
expliquer que les contaminations à
l'extérieur était importante et que le
masque à l'extérieur était une
précaution deux suivants nécessaire et
où je disais ici qu'il n'y avait pas de
contamination extérieure et que de
masquer à l'extérieur n'avaient
absolument aucun fondement
il aura encore fallu un peu plus
longtemps que d'habitude c'est à dire un
mois et demi pour que j'ai raison
mathurin et vous êtes toujours fait ça
c'est vrai fabrice peut-être on avance
oui ça va vous pouvez penser que c'est
prématuré ou pas mais oui moi ce que je
pense et je suis extrêmement je suis ému
aux larmes devant dans cette générosité
de notre président de la république qui
nous restitue les terrasses
mon dieu que c'est beau vous avez vu un
peu tout à l'heure cette émotion en
terrasse que vous avez eue et ses
magnifiques quoi ces français qui sont
en terrasse qui ont la liberté
merci monsieur le président alors
évidemment il ya une autre façon de voir
les choses avec cette liberté elle
m'appartient et que ça fait juste un an
comme l'a piqué mais après donc si
maintenant il faut que je remercie en
plus et ceux qui m'ont pris ma liberté
de me la rendre
bon bah super on peut voir ça
je trouve ça délirant très franchement
et je suis assez d'accord avec votre
père c'est très prématuré les gens vont
se rapprocher
vous savez trés mais vous savez très
bien ici chez nous et la nature et là ce
que c'est pas d'accord avec le pas vous
d'accord vous vous êtes pour la liberté
retrouvée mais non parce que les gens
ils vont rester à cinq à six à dix avant
fin devant prolonger la soirée c'est
dangereux cyril faisant attention
attention
elle n'a pas dit le père que c'était
prématuré il a dit que les gens se
précise et ben je savais qu'ils allaient
se reprocher et que l'ouverture était il
n'a pas dit que l'ouverture était
prématuré dit que c'est le comportement
des gens j'ai effectivement moi j'ai vu
les tableurs match et moi je vais vous
dire il ya vraiment de la place les ya
de l'air un garde est ouvert nicole
panique en sait pas plus mais c'est
intéressant ce que niveau de peur parce
que aujourd'hui ça a baissé à baisser
mais personne n'en parle mais personne
ne veut bien sûr sur les plateaux pour
expliquer pourquoi ça a baissé
oui c'est à dire que pourquoi ça a
baissé il ya il n'y a que 13 % des gens
qui ont été vaccinés deux fois donc
c'est oui pourquoi ça va baisser mais ça
que j'ai c'est ce que cela vire tout
vous expliquer depuis trois mois
l'épidémie est dynamique propre et vous
pouvez faire ce que vous voulez vous
n'arriverez pas à juguler
mais enfin c'est pas vrai division jour
cette baisse sont lavés n'est jamais
évident à l'arrivée des beaux jours
faible salinité trait à l'association
rêves
à ceci près que ce qu'on fait là et
qu'on serre est vrai en grande pompe par
ce que il faut bien rendre honneur à
notre général en chef et bien le texas
ça fait trois mois qu'ils y sont et ce
cas lui martin des rebonds de
contamination non mais fabrice di vizio
vous êtes d'accord qu'il ya quand même
des gens qui ont tout fait pour que ça
se passe pas avec 80% de la communauté
médicale qui tu peux pas dire que
c'était pas un risque de dire qu'on
allait ouvrir le 19 mai et ce risque a
payé puisque ça n'a jamais autant baissé
je rappelle que dominique costagliola
quai quand même grand prix de l'inserm a
dit venus nous voir
webb a très bien elle a dit là ça ne
baissera jamais les mesures qu'ils ont
pris ça va continuer à monter
elle regarde la courbe martin que les
grands crus et des imbéciles qui
racontent n'importe quoi c'est pas
nouveau
bah oui vous avez bien ne pas s'excuser
après pour des raisons du non
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît valérie
benaïm vous chez moi je trouve que c'est
pas du tout trop précipité je pense que
maintenant de notre responsabilité
collective et individuelle de faire en
sorte que justement on ne soit pas qu'on
se soit pas trompé
c'est à dire qu'effectivement qu'on soit
pas les uns sur les autres conçois qu'on
respecte encore les distances malgré
tout mais profitons pour une fois qu'on
est un petit peu optimiste profitons il
y avait 3 3 facteurs ya la santé mentale
la santé physique
et puis il y avait la santé économique
pour la bri pour une fois voilà pourquoi
je vois tu sais pourquoi mais vous
rendez compte de ce que vous dites que
voilà non mais pardonnez moi à un moment
donné il va falloir qu'on soit
responsable
mais enfin [ __ ] pardon hein et aux
émois responsable on n'a été que ça on
est responsable ou et deux blancs doute
en bout on s'est pris plus que n'importe
quelle génération dans la figure et en
un an ces prix injonction contre
injonction ça va dans quatre semaines
on va avoir de l'est on va avoir
effectivement une amélioration ensuite
on nous a vendus de l'espoir ce qui est
plus que ça à vendre donc oui les
français sont responsables oui mais
arrêtez de penser il faut arrêter de
penser que leur dilemme que les le
comportement des français pourrait avoir
une influence majeure sur le cours sur
le titre qu'on était dans l'hiver le
comportement des français
est ce que tu peux expliquer au public
français ce qui se passe au texas et
pourquoi ça se passe comme ça et ça
aussi c'est tout ce qu'on avait dit que
c'était les fous les texans de tours et
ouvrir il ya trois mois
by donne à l'édito pâte et finalement ça
baisse ça fait très chaud texas espace à
bord l'asile à m
si vous voulez un élément c'est que plus
on prend on s'aperçoit que plus on prend
de mesures sanitaires mois on n'a
d'impact sur l'épidémie finalement c'est
ça que nous apprend le texas c'est ça
que nous apprend la floride c'est ça que
nous apprend le portugal dans par
exemple je sais qu'au bol ailleurs il
est vacciné
il en bave à sarno et la vacciner 30 %
la population en gros donc c'est quand
même significatif c'est significatif
pardon ya eu zéro mort au texas harry
est le seul pays dont on sait vente etc
et aux héros morts c'est israël qui a
évacué landes 80 consentent ça peut pas
donc ça veut dire que 30% 80% c'est la
même chose non annoncés m'intéresse si
on à 30% de vacciner et qu on a zéro
mort pourquoi personne s'en est félicité
hier pourquoi j'ai pas entendu les
médias en grand dans mais fabre est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a vacciné une grande
partie soit 50 % de notre population
générale et on est déjà très protégé
contre les bills à ce tarif on n'a pas
besoin d'art 81 % pour déjà avoir bien
avancé dans les vaccins chez carl martin
tu penses que ça
est ce que tu penses pas que c'est vrai
que voilà c'est peut-être là c'était
peut-être un peu tôt donc pensé dans un
an je pense qu'on pouvait pas le faire
plus tard non mais regardez les chiffres
fabrice poursuit c'est trop tard voilà
c'est évidemment peut-être que c'est
trop tard voilà peut-être que ça c'est
plus trop tarder à bah oui non mais
personne ne dit aujourd'hui que c'est
trop tard et que c'est trop tôt ni par m
pour calmer un peu quoi et comment nous
la part en dessous d'une inflammation à
sienne en formation en france à metz
de la santé beaucoup vous devez vous
connaissez tous mon kiné ses
connaissances c'est malheureux mais je
connais pas beaucoup et moi
[Applaudissements]
non là on est sur le débat non j'aurais
aimé déjà avoir plus de personnes
vaccinées je trouve que 30% c'est pas
assez et vous avez vu tous les gens
agglutinés dès 6 heures du matin à huit
heures du matin devant les magasins
devant les cinémas les a isolés le temps
et c'est parti des ayatollahs lui alors
mélange fait d'accord si les capacités
d'accueil sont réduites je ne crois pas
en la responsabilité de chacun je brave
et le verre deux verres trois verres
vous allez voir les gens voient là ça va
être des accolades et machins et tout va
retirer vague
moi je suis là c'est fabrice di vizio et
loire dont il ya un an quand on a des
consignes et je crois qu'on était à
moins de 5000 car on n'avait même pas de
vaccin à quoi ça sert tout ça je pense
que la saisonnalité comme dit fabrice di
vizio ça ne sert à rien vous connaissez
bien sûr mais quand j'en sais rien je
suis posée puisque si je ne sais rien ne
semblait tout savoir non d'écouté
tragiquement après ton sens dire que
c'est juste m'expliquer justin pourquoi
c'est ma seule ma sempiternelle question
à laquelle personne ne répond c'est quoi
pourquoi le texas et la flore m'emmerder
avec votre café des aidants débrouiller
sa réaction
non ça va être soir que caricaturale que
ça elle a quelque chose d'intéressant à
chaque fois la question du texas ou
d'affleurer vous m'emmerder avec le
texas au calme c'est intéressant parce
que j'écris action à quoi qu'on dise
quoi que caricaturale et stupide a bien
sûr une arme il n'en demeure pas moins
qu'elle est quand même celle que tout le
monde a à tout le monde parce d'israël
tout le monde parle deux langues et moi
il ya des pays qui n'ont pas vaccinés à
32 30 ans mais on est encore derrière
ici dit les douleurs et des 30% égal à
90 même sens et que je dis c'est
pourquoi tout le monde se félicite d'un
zéro mort en israël en disant c'est le
modèle à suivre avec 90% en se
félicitant de ce que israël est réouvert
les terrasses et quitter le masque en
extérieur avec 90 bras latine à sion 30%
de vaccination au texas et tout est
ouvert et 30% aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que quand ils ont ouvert ils étaient à
moins que ça comme angers
avez vous une explication saisonnalité
y'a plus de saison en saison
on est serré sans sa soirée soit déjà
soyez connu mais très chaud texas tu
n'es jamais avec texas tu dis pas les
partages pour ça que tu dis ça fait
quelle température au texas
en ce moment il faudrait 25 et 27 c koi
tu mens sens horaire martin en ce moment
même au texas et chaud mais pas toute
l'année et alors s'il fait chaud
la réflexion est intéressante parce que
ra alors au texas il fait chaud en suède
il fait froid oui donc c'est quoi
l'explication de la densité de la
population comme je note c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'on a un chiffre qui est
correct on a toujours une explication
derrière gbagbo sinon travail a vécu
c'est intéressant mais israël il fait
pas chaud en israël
cissé alors donc et en israël il fait
chaud et on a vacciné 90%
l'appropriation c'est grâce au vaccin
mais au texas où il fait chaud il n'a
pas vacciner 30 % des populations c'est
grâce à danser au climat donc vous êtes
en train de m'expliquer qu'israël l'a
vacciné pour rien merci je n'ai pas
besoin alors commence à baisser
alors oui à 35 ans quand même nom à 65%